when you come and tell me your business
is failing because of these two people
that work for you you do understand that
you were the one who hired them and you
were the one that is deciding to let
them still be there one of my favorite
things is talking to entrepreneurs over
the last 15 years is their passion for
who the president is as if that's a
proxy to how successful they are as an
entrepreneur I'm aware that taxes could
change under different presidencies I'm
aware that policies can I'm aware that
there's rules that can be made but the
reality is still at the end of the day
if you're a operator you can operate
around new truths sometimes that's the
consumer Behavior sometimes that's a
political organization but the reality
is you do have a lot of control
including things like you can leave
where you live if you're in Sweden right
now and you're like man it's just harder
to build a huge company in Sweden in
Tech I'm like moved to San Francisco you
could and so I really do love the
happiness that comes along with
accountability